[Music]
my name is rita boncompanie dudabisi
i was married to the late nicolo
bonkampani little vici 12th prince of
pianvino
and he was the head of the family
and this is was our home or is our home
and i've lived here for
almost 20 years this building was built
in 1570 the first owner was cardinal
francesco de monte and when you come
into the ingresso you will see the
ceiling was done by the leading
mannerist painter in 1570 zookery and
although it celebrates the
good works of cardinal francesco nero as
you go around it in the center
there is a
face of the grotesque and as you
you turn as you're looking at it and the
face follows you everywhere it goes and
the eyes change color they go from brown
to blue
and then there's a bald aquino in the
ingresso only families that descend from
popes have the beldoquinos
so it's full of history
it's about 30 000 square feet but it's
two acres of land in the middle of room
you're in the landscape room which was
featured at the grand palais in paris
and also at the prado museum in madrid
in 2010. there's a fresco by guacino
brio viola dominicano the center
promorancho and they said that this is
the finest representation of 17th
century landscape art in the world the
home and the property is what's left of
what was once more than an 85-acre
garden in the center of rome it was a
base garden of its kind in rome the
property was later redeveloped into
separate plots so what along what today
is via veneto which is one of the most
glamorous shopping districts in the
world and the district that's located in
is called ludovisi it's still named
after princess's husband's family the
home will need more than 10 million
dollars worth of renovation it kind of
differs depending on who who you talk to
and what their kind of threshold of what
a livable space is but even though the
princess has done so much renovation
work it still needs some additional
renovation
at the michelangelo statue the reason we
know it's michelangelo because when
ludavika ladyvisi died very suspiciously
in 1633
his his uh they did an inventory of
everything that he had and that was one
of the inventories and he's an expert in
statues every statue you see at palazzo
altimps came from here
i said in the ingresso you see the
leading mannerist painter zookery now
25 or seven years later caravaggio did
the ceiling in the alchemy room of
cardinal francisco de monte he was an
alchemista he's alchemist he he did his
alchemy work there and he thought he
could turn iron into gold which i'm
still searching for but but nonetheless
it was beautiful it's called jupiter
neptune and pluto and it's the three
elements that cardinal francisco de
monte used in his alchemy work jupiter
air
neptune water and then pluto um fire the
dogs of cerebus and so um it represents
the elements the cronus ailments that
that caravaggio used the caravaggio
ceiling is so important just because
caravaggio was such a such an important
artist in art history he's one of the
most famous painters in art history and
there are less than 90 paintings by
caravaggio known to still exist
it's the only painting that carvagio
ever painted on his ceiling and it was
done when he was in his early 20s and
still in very good favor with the
vatican and the wealthy families in rome
later he would end up being chased out
of rome because he killed a man in a
street fight
in guccino's painting here um you'll see
uh there's a man lying on the ground and
he's turning on a sprinkler system
and the women that are on the lower
level are getting all wet in their
summer frock and the men their
boyfriends their husbands are all
laughing at them and pointing this is
long before all the contests in florida
you know it was and they were making fun
of all the women getting all wet and uh
so it's such a human um
humanity that came in there with the
with the people etc etc
[Music]
one thing that i think has been
repeatedly stressed to me by people i've
talked to for the story is how much of a
turnaround the princess moving into the
home was and renovating it was i mean
the house was just completely written
off as ruins and um before that she
moved and it hadn't been opened to the
public in years so thanks to her
restoring the house and digitizing the
archives hopefully even if it sells to
someone private
we still know more about villa aurora
thanks to her more than we ever would
have known
when i was 16
i just graduated from high school and my
parents my sister and i had just
graduated from college to rome with a
kind of a teacher to go all over not
just to rome but all over europe and i
felt such an affinity i can't begin to
tell you i felt like this is something i
feel deeply you can't explain it and
when i went to the trevi fountain
i threw a coin in and i said
oh i hope i marry an italian and live in
rome the rest of my life now little did
i know that it would be a prince or that
it would take decades you know and many
life transitions uh but that's that's
what i wished and uh
my sister and i've never forgotten it
did dinners and tours and
everything i could to support my husband
and i felt i felt it was important and
also i thought it was such a great honor
i know it's like a drop of sand that
my importance in this 500 year old
history is
negligible or maybe not even seen but it
was for me and it was such a great honor
to
restore the 150 000 documents it was
such a great honor to greet people when
they came here and tell them about the
history and and everything to try and
inspire them themselves and their own
lives and uh
so it's it's been the greatest honor of
my life and as
marcus aurelius was feeling is that you
know this was that one
shining golden moment that you know you
did something special in your life and i
know that
i think
just being with my husband to be with
someone who
loved you so much
and
whom taught me how to love and return
it's a gift that
i will never forget you know i'd never
had that before
i never understood what it really meant
to be loved and to love and return in
such a profound way
you know it's not easy it's not easy my
husband gave his life for this house he
did literally we never took a vacation
everybody all of our friends where are
you going in august and we said no we're
staying here and they said but don't you
want to go there i said no i said i'm so
happy just being with him
i think that
niccolo gave me the ability to
to really be happy
and i think i'm going to be i think i'm
going to be
my future is going to be good
[Music]
you